[Music]
this is Craig tiddle thanks doll and
this is Trevor Brock you have a good day
my [__] is [__] massive it always
leaves the ladies sore the money just
keeps rolling in the good times never
stop and there's never been a man like
me and I'll always be on top
cracks it'll travel Brock my two top
salesmen you two [__] look like
y'all could be twins
very dissimilar
[Music]
the only thing I have from the dad I
never knew is half of a locker we must
be brothers that's just brothers Trevor
twins wow we're twins we're [__]
identical twins if mom and dad got
married again then we'd have a real
family what if we trick them into
getting back together
what are you doing here the twins
the services my Palace built they break
my brick so get in the line dropping
your knees and suck my [__] dick
should I open another bottle I know it's
our second but we're not Baptist should
we drown them in the bathtub in the
old-fashioned way y'all [__] up
I'm gay queer is a three dollar bill and
just as thin who like the [__] hand
job
[Applause]
[Music]
wow a lady boss I guess it really is the
year that it is
I'm so sorry did you say sewer boys
disgusting they're not disgusting
they're gay coaches
oh
[Applause]